i have for you today possibly
the dumbest segment in newsmax history
newsmax is one of these
sort of like a lower rent fox news more
extreme by the way if you can imagine
and uh this was an interview that two
news max hosts
did with dick morris d i have to tell
you dick morris is kind of a sad
character at this point dick's in his
mid 70s now he's not super present
publicly
but dick morris was like a big clinton
friend in the early 90s
who eventually had a falling out with
the clintons turned against the clintons
but also became kind of a right-wing
apologist i won't necessarily say he is
a right winger
although after watching this interview
it sounds like he is but certainly a
right-wing apologist
i interviewed dick morris a few years
ago he hated my line of questioning so
much
that he hung up on me you can find that
interview on my youtube channel
so dick morris appears on newsmax right
after the colorado shooting now first of
all
the segment this segment existing at all
aside from what dick says which we will
look at
the segment existing is part of the
silliness newsmax and fox and others
they've been covering the colorado
shooting where we found out the shooter
is muslim
totally differently than the georgia
shooting where the shooter is white and
the victims
were minorities but i'm for this segment
i'm putting aside the structural
hypocrisy
and we're going to focus just on what is
said during the interview
so let's jump right in and look at the
first clip murderers
and their willingness to continually
make excuses for them
uh to your thoughts
well there's a overwhelming point here
which is that
uh the killer was a syrian refugee
and donald trump banned refugees
from terror-sponsoring countries like
syria and donald and joe biden has
opened the floodgates again letting them
in and in fact with specifically
earmarking refugees
he's increased the number of refugees
that can come into the u.s
by a factor of seven or eight so dick
morris's argument
is that the shooter in colorado is
exactly the type of person that donald
trump
banned from the united states but joe
biden is now welcoming to the united
states
the colorado shooter was three years
old when he came to the united states he
was radicalized
in the united states or he became you
know
if we want to go the mental illness
route he he
developed his condition in the united
states and
is essentially an american i mean look i
came to the u.s when i was five
so i was two years older than the
colorado shooter my
upbringing has been shaped here
my education is mostly in the united
states
my political views my interests my
social circle it's all been shaped here
the colorado shooter was
even younger than i was when he came to
the united states
what on earth does this have to do with
syria or
donald trump's ban or joe biden and if
you can believe it it gets even dumber
let's continue
the other point i want to make is if the
democrats are so worried about
gun violence the the most important
thing you can do about gun violence
is to institute the stop and frisk
policy that new york city had until the
democrats
forced it to be out to be stopped okay
so now dick morris says
let's use stop and frisk we're talking
about
mass shootings here individual gun
homicides handgun stuff
okay like you can you can talk about
stop and frisk
of course the problem with stop and
frisk as we saw in new york is its
application was
extremely racially biased but this
segment
is about the causes of a mass shooting
that took place with a rifle
does dick think that police will stop
mass shootings with rifles
with stop and frisk where police just
stumble across a random guy with a
gigantic rifle in his pants on his way
to a mass shooting
it's ridiculous and then it gets even
more ridiculous
when the cop actually sees somebody on
the street
with a gun in a high crime area very
late at night
and can stop them and see if they're
armed if they're not they let them go
if they are they get they get arrested
for a mandatory three-year sentence
for carrying a loaded firearm in the
city of new york now did you hear what
dick said there
stop and frisk is where police can stop
someone if they see them walking around
with a gun that's not stop and frisk
that's you see someone with a gun and
you inquire as to the legal status of
the gun
but then dick says they frisk them and
if they have a gun they get arrested but
dick you just said stop and frisk is
police see someone with a gun and they
stop them but now you're saying stop and
frisk is
if they have a gun after you frisk them
you arrest them it's making no sense
and of course its application to mass
shootings is zero
let's look at a little more of this and
this is funny because the host actually
says
the colorado shooter was only three when
he moved to the us
it doesn't slow dick morris down even
one for a moment
yeah you know um ahmad al alissa he uh
moved here to this country when he was
just three years old
uh but because of some recent activity
of his
he was actually on the the spectrum of
the fbi
so this is another case that the fbi was
aware of him
or at least people near him and watching
him
but yet this was still allowed to happen
that's another conversation a lot of
folks aren't having
yes well i think the the point is that
he comes from a country
that sponsors terrorism syria his
parents did and brought him here at a
young age but
that is precisely the kind of immigrant
that joe biden is letting in
and donald trump wanted to bar so dick
morris hears the kid was
three when he came to the us and the fbi
was aware of him
but he's sticking with this is why we
don't let syrians
into the country so the real story there
is that yet again the fbi has their eye
on someone
and that individual still can get guns
more easily than you can register to
vote in some states with a waiting
period on voter registration right there
are states
where you can't register and vote on the
same day you have to register in advance
and later vote but you can decide
same day to go get a gun and walk out of
the store with it that that day
on the fbi's radar and still was able to
do that
but dick morris says the problem is
i guess we don't have stop and frisk and
the kid came from syria when he was
three
and that relates to joe biden in some
way i have to tell you dick morris has
become sort of a sad
figure in politics and newsmax
allowing him to also expose his
incompetence
um only makes it sadder but making
no sense whatsoever and the news max
host standing aside and letting him do
it
we'll have more on this and i would love
your reaction you can follow us
on instagram at david pakman show and
we will have maybe we'll have a uh an
additional clip of this interview
it's really something to see find us on
instagram at davidpakmanshow
find me on instagram david.pakman if
you've been watching the show you've
probably heard me talk about how much i
love
my helix mattress well i was really
excited to hear that helix has launched
a new company called
all form which makes premium
customizable sofas and chairs
with the same level of quality and
comfort
that i expect from these guys and all
form is one of our sponsors today
they're giving you 20 off at
allforum.com
pacman they actually sent me a couch
which i put
in my living room at home it's now my
favorite piece of furniture
in the house it took me just minutes to
set it up it's solidly built
it's huge it's roomy it has a modern
minimalist design which i love but it's
also
very comfortable fabric is soft clearly
very high quality it has become the
focal point of my living room their
prices are very reasonable and when you
get a new sofa or chair
you get 100 days to decide if you want
to
keep it and the best part is everything
comes
with a lifetime warranty stop buying
poorly made furniture go to customize
your own all form sofa or chair right
now and get
20 percent off your entire order when
you get there
by going to all form dot com slash
pacman
i've also put the link right underneath
this video